So we just filled out that previous code integrating our HTML interpreter
with our JavaScript interpreter,
assuming that our JavaScript interpreter returns a string.
The basic idea is that if the embedded JavaScript code called document.write(x),
we'd notice that x and save it and return it back to you.
Unfortunately, there is an evil problem.
This is a little more complicated than it looks.
This is totally legitimate JavaScript code.
Note that I have 1 call to document.write and then another call to document.write.
Somehow I'm going to need to paste together "hello" and "world" and return both of them.
So the basic problem here is that there may not be just 1 call to write.
There may be many more or actually there may be 0,
but we want to get out of this "hello-space-world!"
So we have to store text printed by write,
but we may find that as we execute or interpret the JavaScript program,
the amount of output grows.
Well, if we want to store values that may change--
boy, if only we already had some way to do that--oh wait! We totally do.
We went to all that trouble to learn about how environments work
in nested environments and variable updates.
Let's reuse that. That was really powerful!